[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de france 24 en
el mes de abril el tribunal supremo
españoles determinó que la gestación
subrogada vulnera los derechos
fundamentales de gestantes y bebés y que
por lo tanto los contratos de gestación
subrogada son nulos de pleno derecho
decidió además que el reconocimiento de
la relación de filiación a la madre no
biológica debe obtenerse por la vía de
la adopción la sentencia como el tema de
la maternidad por sustitución es una
polémica constante en el mundo y en este
programa decidimos abordarlo desde sus
orillas entendiendo que se usan
argumentos que abogan por el feminismo
tanto a favor como en contra
precisamente para comprender los
argumentos en la maternidad subrogada
invitamos a dos expertas en su materia y
quiero comenzar con nuria gonzález ella
es abogada y activista feminista
española por los derechos de las mujeres
y de los niños también es máster en
derechos humanos con especialidad en
bioética y además es autora del libro
vientre de alquiler
talento femenino bienvenida a nuria
gracias por estar con nosotros y el
derecho a la integridad sobre el propio
cuerpo no puede ser un objeto de
contrato lo dice la asociación activista
con europea que se llama no somos
vasijas usted qué opina
que tienen razón es que el cuerpo no
puede ser no puede estar sometido a
ningún tipo de acuerdo contractual ni el
de las mujeres ni el de los bebés y eso
es exactamente lo que lo que dice el
tribunal pero que ya lo dijo en 2014
operarse reafirmar más si un caso lo
novedoso de estas sentencias que pone el
foco sobre el papel de las agencias no
hay todo el negocio alrededor de los
vientres de alquiler de la explotación
reproductiva pero lo que reafirma es que
ningún ser humano está sometido a
contrato claro sin embargo otras
posturas dirían que es feminista
reconocer y respetar la autonomía de las
mujeres de hecho yo sé que usted también
diría algo así pero cuando ya no se
entienden es cuando se habla de que la
gestación por sustitución podría ser
entendida como una expresión de
autonomía cuál es su postura
ninguna no hay nada de feminista en la
explotación reproductiva el mito de la
libre elección es el mismo mito de la
que la prostitución no parece que todas
las mujeres prostituídas están ahí
porque quieren no es cierto de estas
maneras en el caso de las vientres de
alquiler va un paso más allá porque
realmente nada tiene que ver con la
autonomía del cuerpo de la mujer vender
a un bebé o regalar a un bebé no estamos
hablando de la transacción comercial por
luego comercial o gratuita de una
tercera persona que es la que nace por
lo tanto eso en lana tiene que ver con
la autonomía de las mujeres tres huelgas
que es muy interesante señalar lo que a
las mujeres siempre se nos da libertad
para vendernos como prostitutas o como
bienes alquiler
bueno y a propósito de eso pues hablemos
del turismo de bebés que ustedes
denuncian y por ejemplo el caso más
conocido por estos días dada la guerra
en europa del este pues es el caso de
ucrania nuevo sí claro gracias el útero
de europa es donde más europeos van
concretamente donde más españoles van
por un tema de economía
tiene que saber que ucrania es el país
donde menos se respetaban los derechos
humanos de antes de la guerra
específicamente en el tema de los
dientes de alquiler donde las mujeres
eran más precarias estamos hablando de
un país en el que el salario medio no
llegaba a los 200 euros al mes y ante
esas condiciones económicas de
desesperación pues había muchas mujeres
que estaban dispuestas a ser vientres de
alquiler y además ellos tienen
legalizado lo que es el modelo comercial
ellos se dedican a vender niños y eso es
lo que es su explotación ellos explotan
ellos trafican ellos exportan 2500 bebés
al año
su negocio mire lo que denuncia esta
postura feminista es que lo que hay
cuando se dan los casos de subrogación o
de maternidad por su sustitución
tiene más que ver con tráfico humano que
con maternidad es usted cree que hay una
actividad de que no haya tráfico humano
es decir que por ejemplo no esté dado
por un contrato sino que haya una
voluntad real de una mujer para querer
donar o prestar su vientre por nueve
meses para que por ejemplo una pareja
diversa pueda acceder a la maternidad o
la paternidad
no en absoluto es que que es dorar tu
vientre si al final no entregas el fruto
de tu vientre para que nos entendamos
nos da la capacidad de gestar sin parir
una criatura no es nada es como la
capacidad de volar simplemente no existe
no y también utilizar al colectivo gay
como si fuera una red un reclamo del
colectivo gay o un derecho del colectivo
gay el explotar a otras mujeres para
tener para ser supuestamente ser padres
pues también es una falacia porque el
colectivo gay puede adoptar y son padres
exactamente igual a que se está hablando
de explotar reproductivamente a mujeres
pobres
sobre la falacia y la falsedad jurídica
de que los niños se pueden vender o
regalar nadie puede vender o regalar a
una persona ni siquiera a su propia
madre no porque pues háganlo va a sacar
a la calle regalen a sus hijos a ver
dónde acaban sus hijos de ustedes
entonces en la cárcel y sus hijos del
servicio social no habrá dinero de por
medio entendería por eso que entonces
para ustedes la única vía para las
personas que no pueden gestar de manera
biológica sería la adopción o
simplemente renunciar a esa posibilidad
de ejercer paternidad es y maternidades
y bueno ya se nos viene acabando el
tiempo pero quería preguntarle otra de
las grandes dudas que surgen y que
generan debates si una mujer puede dar
consentimiento informado siendo una
mujer gestante sabiendo que su estado
traerá unos cambios hormonales propios
de la gestación que además podrían
influir no solamente en sus emociones
sino en sus decisiones entonces
en ese misma en esta misma línea hemos
visto activistas que estaban a favor de
la gestación subrogada después fueron
madres y se volvieron en contra
completamente no hay ninguna feminista
dentro de alquiler si hay mujeres a
favor lo que tranquilas desde luego no
socialistas pero volvemos al argumento
en sí las mujeres cuentan todo el
consentimiento que quieran pero al final
esto no se trata sólo del cuerpo de las
mujeres el cuerpo las mujeres aquí es
explotado y utilizado como una máquina
como un medio de producción lo que
importa al final es la entrega del niño
de la niña que nace por lo tanto da
igual las decisiones de tutores sobre su
propio cuerpo porque al final lo único
que importa es la transacción de un ser
humano por eso no hay ninguna
posibilidad de que los vientres de
alquiler sean algo más que algo abolir
en todo el mundo
pues muchísimas gracias a usted nuria
por la información por los argumentos
informados que nos entrega y sobre todo
por exponer pues muy claramente esta
postura le deseo un feliz día y quiero
continuar con nuestra siguiente invitada
estaba con nosotros también en ellas hoy
estaré farnós ella es profesora de
derechos civiles de la universitat
pompeu fabra y autora del artículo la
reproducción asistida ante el tribunal
europeo de derechos humanos publicado en
la revista de bioética y derecho esther
gracias a usted también por estar con
nosotros ya vimos una postura
completamente en contra de la maternidad
o de la
gestación por sustitución varios países
como españa que prohíben estas esta
gestación por sustituciones se basan en
que la madre es solamente la gestante
como reta para usted ese concepto el de
una familia diversa que también aspira a
ejercer maternidad es y paternidades
bueno buenas tardes en primer lugar
bueno en primer lugar resaltar que el
concepto de que la maternidad se
determina
únicamente por el hecho del parto ya ha
sido superado hay una mujer que es madre
y que evidentemente no ha aportado la
gestación y muchas veces ni tan solo su
óvulo entonces yo creo que
bueno mi posición es más matizada es
decir creo que no debe admitirse todo
creo que acuerdos de gestación subrogada
como los que se discutían en la reciente
sentencia del tribunal supremo- española
no son admisibles y no deben ser
reconocidos de ningún tipo pero creo que
hay casos de altruismo en los que
debería reconsiderarse la posibilidad de
dar validez legal a un acuerdo de
gestación por sustitución al que ha
accedido a una pareja heterosexual o una
pareja de dos hombres o incluso un
hombre sólo escuchando sus
intervenciones en investigaciones sobre
el tema pues usted habla mucho del caso
de españa- pero también nos ha hablado
del caso de portugal donde si bien
argumentos todavía se encuentran vacíos
legales que tienen que ver sobre todo
con las mujeres gestantes y sus
opiniones y sus sentimientos alrededor
de todo este tema de la gestación por
sustitución
sí yo creo que desde el derecho hay
instrumentos
a controlar no sólo que el
consentimiento de la mujer que está para
otro es un consentimiento informado sino
que no hay explotación que es lo que me
parece más importante
portugal ha legislado recientemente esta
cuestión y como otros países que la han
legislado y la pretenden legislar con
una serie de garantías impone una serie
de requisitos no se puede ser gestante
más de 23 veces a lo largo de la vida de
una mujer este es un requisito que
encontramos de forma muy común en
algunos ordenamientos
no se puede pagar
a la gestante y menos a las agencias que
hay de por medio la gestante tiene que
ser una mujer que previamente ha gestado
y ha traído un hijo propio al mundo para
saber lo que lo que implica la gestación
y muy importante en el caso por ejemplo
del reino unido y en el caso de portugal
el tribunal constitucional portugués
inicialmente no permitió que la ley de
gestación se aprobara puesto que pidió
que se reconsiderara en el tema de la
posibilidad de la gestante de cambiar de
opinión en la gestante siempre tiene el
derecho a revocar
en reino unido por ejemplo una vez ha
nacido el bebé
tienen que transcurrir seis meses para
que este bebé pueda ser podríamos decir
adoptado o ser considerado hijo de los
comitentes a través de una orden
parental
y creo que estos son requisitos y
garantías que bueno que de alguna manera
aseguran que lo que se está produciendo
es un acuerdo en el que se han respetado
los derechos de las partes implicadas
pero sobre todo los derechos de la mujer
gestante y los del nacido nacida bueno
esther pero ahí existe entonces una
presión emocional fuertísima para esa
familia o esa pareja que está esperando
recibir un bebé a través del método de
la gestación subrogada y además se
quisiera preguntarle hay diferencia de
usted como abogada una diferencia entre
la gestación subrogada y los vientres de
alquiler
sí creo que si hablamos de vientres de
alquiler y la terminología nunca es
neutra estamos presuponiendo que
hay un acuerdo comercial
gestación por subrogación no implica la
existencia de un acuerdo
comercial sino que puede implicar casos
de altruismo claro y voy a poner
ejemplos por ejemplo yo gesto para mi
hermano que por su opción vital vive en
pareja con otro hombre
estoy de acuerdo en que la adopción
debería ser la primera alternativa
pero la adopción internacional y algo
por el caso de españa está muy limitada
y es positivo que cada vez haya menos
niños de otros países en situación de
ser adoptado es algo que creo que merece
una lectura positiva a nivel nacional
hay niños que pueden ser adoptados pero
por suerte cada vez menos y hay otros
recursos las familias las propias
familias etcétera no entonces en una
sociedad en que la adopción ya no es
siempre una opción y pienso también en
parejas gays que no pueden acceder a
adopción porque los países que permiten
adoptar no les permiten a ellos adoptar
por su opción sexual deberían tener la
opción de la gestación subrogada
a cualquier precio no en cualquier caso
y repito creo que la reciente sentencia
del tribunal supremo da un toque de
atención de que no todo es posible y no
todo debe ser reconocido pues muy bien
muchísimas gracias a ustedes tener como
le dije nuria gracias por sus opiniones
informadas o por un punto de vista que
no se permite conocer más del tema al
final lo que buscamos en ellas hoy
siempre es educar y comprender a
profundidad gracias a ustedes por estar
con nosotros y sigan en france 24
[Música]